What are we doing right?
The key thing the irs is doing wrong in
terms of energy policy overall,
I think he's letting congress mandate
foolish,
uh,
legislation like the ethanol scam,
the congress in,
in December of 2007 passed the energy
independence and security act of 2007
and in doing so mandated the production
of 36 billion gallons of ethanol by
2022.
It is not going to happen.
Um,
this,
I mean that what they have done is
mandate the creation of a huge amount of
motor fuel that the market cannot
supply.
But what is also happening is that they
are increasing demand for corn and
thereby and therefore other grains and
it's causing enormous amounts of
inflation in food prices and it's
hurting consumers all over the country.
So I think what the u s has been doing
wrong with regard to energy policy is
allowing Congress to meddle too much in
the market and mandate certain solutions
that are not economic and are not
helpful.
Um,
what is the US doing?
Right?
Uh,
you know,
I don't have to think about that one
because there are no,
there are no answers that come to mind.
I think that we've,
we've really,
uh,
the mistake that we are making as well,
in addition to the ethanol is relying on
militarism.
The U S has really,
since the 1970s,
in particular,
had an approach to energy security that,
uh,
and that requires wrongly over
militarization of the Persian Gulf,
which I think has been a very,
had very deleterious effects on the u s
uh,
the second Iraq war was,
no matter how you slice it,
was in fact about controlling the flow
of oil out of Iraq and resting the
control of Iraqi oil from Saddam
Hussein.
Meanwhile,
other countries around the world have,
uh,
have,
have turned to the marketplace.
They are not using militarism as a way
to,
uh,
trying to assure energy supply and they
are thriving and we're going bankrupt.
Okay.